well it started during the pandemic to
get kids outside get them healthy and
now it's a full-fledged holiday effort
to collect Sports balls and raise funds
joining me now founder and CEO of
Greater Youth Sports Association Devonte
Woodson thank you for being here as well
as Sarah goitz from Vegas sports
Realtors now you guys are here you've
joined together in this partnership to
basically help out all the kids here in
our community tell us a little bit about
this fundraiser and how people can get
involved yes so the holiday sports ball
drive it all started actually during the
pandemic when all the schools were
everything was shot so everything was
shut down my background is that I was a
PE teacher so I knew instantly like a
lot of the students that I would serve
in our low income communities they
already knew like they didn't have
anything at home yeah they didn't have
access to these a lot of students come
to school that's where the equipment is
that's where you know the lunches and
all that stuff like schools are like
safe houses for at least
so knowing that I was like okay we got
to do something to get them exercising
at home and get them balls get them
equipment to their house because we're
trying to do exercises all this stuff
and it's like if you don't have balls
are they're going to do anything yeah
yeah turn around and that's not not
that's not enough you need that team
effort that is a sporting event exactly
so we run a sports program at the school
so instead of you know uh being live we
couldn't be live with the kids so we're
like hey let's collect Sports balls and
then we could give them out to the youth
that need it so that way they can stay
active and enjoy like the sports even
though it's not live at least they could
play at home yeah they have the items so
um but Devonte and Sarah you guys teamed
up you are collecting these balls it is
Saturday and now I know we're just
looking at some video from the past two
events so you're collecting from 11 to 2
on Saturday and you want people to drop
off every kind of sporting ball so what
a volleyball soccer balls football yes
and and Sarah you were mentioning in the
break that there's going to be some uh
some local athletic celebrities there as
well yeah so we do a lot of work with
the athletes from UNLV on the football
team and on the basketball team and
we're really fortunate we're gonna have
a couple guys show up from the football
team in particular that just declared
that they're going to be entering the
draft okay so we're super excited the
teams have been very supportive of
everything that we've been doing so
we're really looking forward to it so
that's awesome so this is going to be a
family-friendly event that everybody can
show up and and now as far as the
distribution of these items that's not
taking place Saturday that's going to be
another time correct yes so Sarah here
um was able to I think she had a
background in fostered Youth and
everything like that so so now we're
going to be actually donating the boss
to Foster Youth and also at risk youth
in our community too great Okay so foot
home oh see
yeah
and we're running out of time but this
is what you're going to donate you're
going to go on Saturday 11 to 2 and it's
at the location is Windmill and 215.
phase one Elite Sport training wonderful
okay guys we're gonna put all this
information on our website please help
out if you can get those kids the the
items that they need to have some fun
and be athletic and enjoy that team that
team feeling uh stick around we've got
more coming up